this is a production of cornell
university
all right well thank you everyone for
coming today um and thanks so much for
your introduction steve
i'm going to first introduce my program
a little bit i know that steve did as
well um so we'll do a little bit of an
introduction of the resources we have
for you
and then i'm going to define
incompatibility and then we'll kind of
get into the meat of the talk and that's
where we'll be talking about how to
avoid incompatibility issues
so as steve said i'm the director and
educator with our program cornell
cooperative extension pesticide safety
education program we go by cce psep and
we were formerly pmep
and we've been a leader in pesticide
safety education for over 40 years
and you know steve mentioned that we
provide training we answer questions and
we serve as an objective source of
information about pesticides for both
applicators and consumers
and what might be of interest to you is
we have applicator certification manuals
and so we write and publish those
manuals
which you can use to study for your
certification exam
and you can purchase those online
through the cornell store at the link
here
and the manuals of interest to you would
include probably fruit and vegetables so
we have category 22 and 23 we also have
the core manual
we also have uh in addition to the live
talks that i'm giving today we give
talks like this but we also give
on-demand recertification courses that
are online so you can just go to our
distance learning center uh
you know this might be a little bit
harder to read but you can see there's a
wide variety of talks from
recertification credits in new york
state and also nine other northeast
states um and they cover core and
category topics so this might be of
interest to you if you're looking to get
some more credits
and then we also publish the cornell
crop and pest management guidelines
and we're currently selling the 2022
guidelines uh
the guidelines that might be of interest
to you are probably you know vegetable
tree fruit and barrier out also field
crops
and you can purchase those online as
well
okay so now that i've kind of shown off
our program resources a little bit here
um
i do a little bit of housekeeping so
uh in this talk there's some pesticide
trade names that are included
and the sole purpose of having those
trade names in there is to explain
common
compatibility issues they're just
examples i'm not endorsing the products
mentioned here and if i don't mention
something it's not because i'm
criticizing it
and please know that you know i'm only
sharing sections of the label you have
to read the entire label
specific to your product before you go
to purchase mix load store or apply it
to make sure you're using that product
correctly
okay now that we've gotten through all
that housekeeping um let's get into
things so when we think about
incompatibility you know the first thing
i kind of want to zoom out first and
really talk about
why uh do we run into this problem and
mainly it's tank mixing right so
let's talk about the benefits of tank
mixing first uh before we get into
incompatibility issues
so
you know there are many upsides to tank
mixing
it can help you make more timely
applications you often have a very
narrow window of time where your pest is
in the correct life stage and weather
conditions to allow for you to
effectively use chemical controls right
and mixing multiple products in one
application
can reduce expenses associated with
labor
time wear and equipment
and
you can also reduce soil compaction um
or crop damage just by not going out as
often right and you can improve control
with tanks mixing by hitting a pest with
multiple different products
and then you can also manage multiple
pests in one application by for instance
you know mixing an herbicide and an
insecticide together
or combining pre and post-emergent
herbicides to manage multiple different
species of wheat at the same time
so there's a lot of benefits to tank
mixing and you know before you take mix
you have to make sure the following
things are true you want to make sure
that none of the pesticide labels
prohibit that mix the timing is right
for efficacy of each pesticide against
the target pests
that the application method is used
that you're using is appropriate for all
pesticides that mix
and you want to make sure that mixing
those pesticides won't lead to
incompatibility
and so that's what we're going to focus
on today is the incompatibility piece of
it so first let's define incompatibility
so incompatibility occurs when you're
mixing two or more pesticide products
together and that negatively influences
how the other pesticide products in the
tank disperse mix and deliver
so basically incompatibility is where
one or more of your pesticide products
are no longer effective for pest control
because you mix them with another
product
and there's two types of incompatibility
that we're going to talk about so you've
got physical incompatibility this is
kind of the more obvious one right it's
the failure of pesticide products to
stay uniformly mixed in the spray tank
and you're going to see all sorts of
horrible stuff
you've seen some of these pictures here
the products fail to stay uh uniformly
mixed that you're seeing separation into
layers of putties and pastes
clogging of screens and nozzles uh this
is difficult to clean and it can render
the products ineffective or impossible
to spray and then if you have you know
some of that left in your tank you can
actually those residues can cause injury
to your crops later on if it's not
cleaned properly
and the other type of incompatibility is
chemical incompatibility
and so this occurs when you're mixing
two pesticides together
are two or more and the activity of one
of those pesticides is reduced
um so you're going to see reduced
efficacy or even undesirable crop damage
um
and the only indication often of
chemical incompatibility is the lack of
results
or efficacy okay so if you've ever mixed
a tank application in the field
that was mysteriously ineffective that's
probably due to a chemical
incompatibility it's very rarely visible
so regardless of which type of
incompatibility you have uh there's
really negative consequences right you
might have to repeat the applications to
control your pests or even switch
products
if repeat application violates the label
direction on that product
if you applied spilled or have to
dispose of the mixture then the
resultant mixture that could be
considered an environmental contaminant
right because it didn't provide any
benefit for pest control and now it's in
the environment
incompatibility waste time money
and product and as we talked about a
little bit it can damage your equipment
and it can also injure your crop for
example with phytotoxicity there's a lot
of obvious incentives to avoiding
incompatibility
and so that's what we're going to talk
about now and this is just kind of an
overview of what we'll talk about today
uh mostly focusing on avoiding
incompatibility so we'll talk about only
mixing a few
things reading the label mixing in order
mixing correctly knowing your carrier
properties conducting jar tests
accounting for multiple factors and then
finally we'll talk about resolving
incompatibility if it should happen to
you but most of what we'll talk about
today is avoiding it
so the first way to avoid compatibility
issues
uh
is to only mix a few products mixing
fewer products reduces your chance of
incompatibility
so to get into why this is
let's talk about what goes into your
tank
we've already discussed you're putting
pesticides in your tank and we're
talking about things like herbicides
fungicides and sex science depending on
pesticides formulation
they might respond differently to things
like temperature water ph storage
conditions
mixing in the carrier and mixing with
other pesticide products
so
let's talk about what makes up a
pesticide
if you remember back to your core
training a pesticide formulation
is the active ingredient plus the inert
ingredients right together that makes up
the formulation so for example we have
roundup pro it's a broad spectrum
post-emergency herbicide
and the pesticide
product name is roundup pro the active
ingredient is glyphosate and you can see
highlighted here it's a specific salt
form
and then 50
uh 8 or 59 of this product
is listed as other ingredients and those
are the inert ingredients
you're probably familiar with a lot of
these inert ingredients um
but
you know what they do is they improve
efficacy so the active ingredient is the
thing that's actually preventing
destroying repelling and mitigating the
pests
and the inert ingredients actually
improving efficacy uh shelf life
application ease and applicator safety
and it can do things like reduce
segregation from sunlight for example or
help penetrate the active ingredient
into a weed
and so inner ingredients include things
like solvents and anti-drift and wetting
agents
antifreeze and ph buffers
d foamers
so when you're taking mixing two or more
pesticides together
you know when you think about how
complicated the formulation can be it
makes sense that simply because of those
complex formulations you might see
incompatibility because it's often the
inert ingredient that composes
incompatibility issues
now think about everything else that
goes into your tank okay you've got
fertilizers macronutrients
micronutrients plant
growth regulators spray dyes
biostimulants okay and all of these
substances can interact with one another
and with the water and with your
pesticides and the carrier's ph
um
and the temperature and the mineral
content resulting in compatibility okay
so this is really why
if you can reduce the number of products
that you're mixing you're going to have
less chance of thinking ability
now i'd be remiss as a pesticide safety
educator if i didn't talk about
this so when you're mixing pesticides
together you have to follow the
strictest label okay and i'm sure you've
heard of this um but let's just take an
example here so you've got product a and
product a requires a rei of eight hours
and product b is four hours okay so
product a is a little more strict here
and then product a requires chemical
resistant gloves and product b requires
us gloves but also protective eyewear
and a respirator
so we're mixing these two together you
know what rei are we going to be
expecting and what level of ppe
well it's going to be the strictest from
each thing
so
you know
when you mix things together basically
the hazards posed by each pesticide are
still present okay so whatever houses
there were that that required product a
to have that eight hour rei that's still
there right
and um the same thing for product b you
know maybe there was a respiratory
concern maybe like an inhalation hazard
of some sort that's still gonna be true
when you mix things together so that's
why you follow the strictest label
so the next way to avoid incompatibility
um is to read the label
now product labels can tell you a lot of
different things regarding compatibility
okay
so they have statements about other
products that are tested for
compatibility with your pesticide the
order in which to add products
recommendations for tank mix agitation
products not to mix
sensitivities to temperature
warnings about ph of water hardness
recommended carrier volume
and whether you need to
tank mix and adjuvant okay so all those
things can be on the
label
but i do want you to keep in mind that
compatibility issues are only sometimes
and not always mentioned on the label
so in red here i'm just going to give
you one example
uh and that's you know this example of
other products so sometimes the label
will list other products tested for
compatibility with your product right
but they don't always do it
um
so companies will test formulations with
other products that applicators might
apply during the season but they do not
account for every possible tank mix
okay and so
um you know this is just an example
that you really gotta make sure to
um
you know keep in mind that that's not
always going to be on the label right so
really
when it comes down to it
you're the one that's responsible for
knowing if the products in your tank are
compatible
and hopefully what we're talking about
today will help with that
so one of the major reasons that
mixtures become incompatible are we
seeing compatibility issues is that
products were mixed in the incorrect
order
so mixing water is really important to
understand so let's start by talking
about mixing order with water as your
carrier okay and we're going to touch on
fertilizer as your carrier next
we're going to start with water here um
okay so the first thing to do like i
just stressed is to read and follow any
instructions on the label
and contact the manufacturer or you can
contact our program with any questions
okay so if the label touches on mixing
at all you have to follow with the
labels set if the label doesn't talk
about you know the mixing order
then there's kind of this generic order
that i'm going to present to you okay
so this is the generic order if your
label doesn't say anything else okay
it's kind of a rule of thumb procedure
here
so what you're going to do is you're
going to agitate liquid products in
their containers
as per the label instructions to ensure
that they're thoroughly mixed before you
add them to the tank then you're going
to add your water to the tank and
usually recommend about 50 of the
required volume
and then you're going to start agitation
of that tank before you even add the
first product you're going to continue
agitation throughout the mixing process
and then you want to add products to
your tank in order based on formulation
so in blue here i'm going to give you
the order the formulation order okay
so this is not otherwise specifying the
label this is the order you're going to
follow
so first you want to add water soluble
bags
okay then you want to add your dry
formulations including dry flowables and
soluble rainbows and this is because
these formulations must be mixed with
water carrier with moderate agitation
you want those particles to break apart
and the surfactants to dissolve
and remember if you follow the mixing
order that we just talked about you
already have been agitating the water
okay so um that will already be starting
now you want to make sure to give your
dry formulations enough wait time to
properly mix with water and part of this
is that you really should be only adding
one of these at a time
so you want to add the dry products one
at a time and then wait for each of them
to disperse before you add the next one
and this will give time for them to mix
and also then if you encounter
incompatibility you're going to lose
less product okay because you'll catch
it early you're not going to have to mix
them all at once
with the water soluble packets you want
to visually ensure that those bags have
fully dissolved and the product has
dispersed okay and the kind of rule of
thumb for each of these dry formulations
is about three to five minutes but this
can really vary a lot and we're going to
touch on this later in the talk
but you know one of the factors that can
change that wait time
is the temperature of the water
the next thing that can be added is the
dry or liquid ammonium sulfate after
this step you could add the dry or solid
anti-drift agents and then the
compatibility agents and anti-foamers
you're going to want to wait 2-3 minutes
after you add the compatibility agents
and anti-foamers before you go to the
next step
now while we have compatibility agents
anti-foamers of step five in this
generic order you want to keep in mind
that um
they're not necessarily subject to a
typical mixing order protocol so you
really want to check for those uh
defomers
and
the compatibility agents and see if the
label says anything about when to add
them and especially with the
anti-foamers you know you're kind of
putting those in a lot of times you want
to put those in throughout the mixing
process
so yeah just make sure to check the
labels there
next up you're going to add all liquid
formulations that have dispersed active
ingredients such as suspension
concentrates suspo emulsions emulsions
in water micro capsules and flowables
and so this picture shows a suspension
in water on the left
the next thing you do is if you're
planning to add emulsifiable
concentrates or ecs to your mixture
you'll want to add polymer-based drift
retardants first in step seven so you're
going to add those liquidus retardants
and that allows the ec formulation to
absorb water and avoid clumping okay so
then next you would add those remaining
liquid formulations which include the
emulsifiable concentrates and also oil
dispersions and salt solutions or
soluble liquids
and because the ecs are oil or
solvent-based products they require more
time to disperse throughout the solution
the picture shown here shows an emulsion
in water on the right so often emulsions
appear milky
okay next you're going to add any
remaining adjuvants such as crop oil
concentrates high surfactant oil
concentrates methylated seed oils
non-ionic surfactants spreader stickers
and our conditioning agents
and then you're going to add
micronutrients and liquid fertilizers
okay so now that you know the order to
mix let's talk about why it's so
important that things are mixed in this
order
if not otherwise stated in the label
so it really comes down to formulation
and the properties of the products with
these specific formulation types and i
highlighted those in yellow here so as
we mentioned dry formulations require
agitation the particles must break apart
and must
dissolve in water
suspensions
um such as suspect emotions and
suspension concentrates are suspended in
water with a thickener or pre-mixed with
oils
and that oil often stays in the tank's
surface
once you add those okay and then
emulsifiable concentrates
they contain surfactants in their
formulation that keep the oil droplets
small
so we're kind of we're talking about two
different things here we're talking
about something that needs to disperse
in water and it's dry and then we're
talking about you know other products
that have oils or thickeners in them and
so you can imagine that if we were to
add the
dry ingredients
second what would happen is they would
hit that oil that's already on top of
the tank
and then that oil would coat them right
then they're going to sink down to the
bottom they're not going to be able to
interact and disperse in the water
um
and so that is why you want to add those
dry ingredients first
so after you add the products in this
order
the next thing you do when you're mixing
is you're going to add the remaining
water you're going to continue agitation
until the tank mix appears uniform
and then you want to measure the ph and
water hardness to determine the proper
levels of water conditioners or ammonium
sulfate that you might need to add if
the ph is out of range and while it's
always a good rule of thumb to check the
pa after you've mixed everything
you want to keep in mind that ph
adjusters are not always added at the
end and the label will tell you when to
add them so you might have to add a
different time during the mixing process
we're going to talk about ph and also
water hardness
a little bit later on in the talk
so we talked about the mixing order here
but it's important to stress this is the
order to follow only if the product
labels do not have their own
instructions for mixing i think i've
said that a couple times here but i want
to give you an example
so my example is senstar and i heard
from a new york state extension
associate with the cornell cooperative
extension vegetable program uh kristy
hopetig that
this new product um sunstar you know for
control of onion thrips on onion among
other sites and pests had some tank
mixing issues
and what was happening is it was forming
into a glob that had to be disposed of
and you know we couldn't be sure exactly
what the source of these tank mixing
issues was
but when you look at the tank mixing
order on the senstar label you can see
that it doesn't follow the generic
mixing order that i just showed you for
most pesticides
so in fact it jumps around quite a bit
and you can see the numbers i have here
you know correspond to the generic
mixing order so you can see that sensor
label requires you to add oil
dispersions in the third step and
typically this wouldn't happen until the
eighth step under the generic mixing
order so things like this are exactly
why it's really important to read the
label to avoid
incompatibility
so far we've just been talking about
mixing with water but what if your
carrier is fertilizer what adjustments
should you make
so most pesticide products are actually
designed to be used with water okay and
water tends to be a better carrier than
for those products and take mixtures
one of the problems is that liquid
fertilizers are essentially a
concentrated salt solution and so
there's going to be less water available
to help disperse your dry formulations
so incompatibility is more likely to
occur when you have fertilizer
as your solution
and then the salts can also mix with
inert ingredients in your product
so knowing this
um
it makes sense you see some changes to
the mixing order with fertilizer so
first you're going to see that you
should always conduct a jar test with
fertilizer as your carrier to avoid that
incompatibility
also when you're using for lighter
carriers you never want to pre-mix crop
protection products in an inductor
and some products are not designed to be
added directly to liquid fertilizer
mixtures that's important to know
similar to water carrier you want to
make sure to agitate the fertilizer
mixture before adding the ingredients
but it's even more important with
fertilizer because things are less
likely to disperse
compared to water
also with fertilizer you always want to
check for incompatibilities after mixing
because they're more likely to happen
and you know there's not a big change
here to the
order that you want to add your products
um
in terms of you know formulation but
you'll see that you are encouraged to
make these pre-slurries okay so with
fertilizer you want to make pre-slurries
and water
um
with these
dry products before you put them into
the tank and that helps them dissolve
before they even go into the fertilizer
carrier
so let's talk about pre-stories a little
bit more
here these two pictures on the right
show an example of a dry herbicide being
added directly to urea and ammonium
nitrate
on the top versus being mixed in a
pre-slurry with water and then add it to
the fertilizer carrier on the bottom and
you can see that you know that
pre-slurry made a huge difference in
terms of dispersion uh why are there
still layers here well you know this
hasn't been agitated yet okay so
that would help get rid of the layers
but you can see freezers are really
important for fertilizer carriers
and remember when you're mixing a
pre-slurry you want to reduce exposure
okay there's going to be an inhalation
hazard with those dry ingredients
there's going to be increased risk of
splashing and sloshing because you're
mixing in an open bucket so pay
attention to label language um and you
know make sure to wear
ppe including gloves eye and skin
protection in case of splashing and take
extra care when you pour that into the
tank
so now that we've talked about
the mixing order for both water and
fertilizer
let's discuss
the three main things you want to be
aware of
so we're going to talk about mixing
correctly
and the first thing we'll talk about is
carrier volume
so just like when you're adding sugar to
your tea
right if you don't have enough water
that sugar is going to precipitate out
and not dissolve and it'll end up at the
bottom of your cup so this is similar
with pesticides okay and so you have to
make sure to add the right amount of
water pesticides will dissolve
otherwise you're going to eat product
clumping at the bottom
typically the directions on the label
state the tank should be half full of
water
and three ports full of fertilizer
before you add the first product
next let's go let's talk about wait time
and we already went over wait time a
little bit but you just want to make
sure to check that each of your products
have mixed that had enough time to mix
before you add the next one
you want to agitate those products
before you add another product
especially when the active ingredients
do not disperse or suspend quickly in
water and keep in mind that a product
may appear to have dispersed when it
actually hasn't completely dissolved so
even though it appears dissolves it
actually might need a little more time
um
and then note that mixing time can be a
lot slower when water is colder we're
going to talk about that in a second
finally let's discuss agitation
so you want to agitate your tank
mixtures moderately before and during
spray applications so what i mean by
moderate agitation well if you're doing
moderate agitation you're going to be
able to see that top layer of your
mixture moving when you look into the
tank if it looks like boiling water
that's too much agitation
why is it so important to not over under
agitate
okay if you over agitate what you're
going to get is dry product formulations
will foam when they remain at the top
and they'll swell and sink
and that can lead to uneven dispersion
or even clogged and stop pumps
you can also get
pesticides dislodging from their
surfactants and this can destabilize the
mixture and you can get clumping and
cottage cheese
and then anti-drift agents can shear
if things are over agitated and that
will lead to diminishing effectiveness
during the course of application
so moderate agitation and also adding
that anti-foaming agent should help
ensure that products are dispersed
without foaming
now you can also under mix your products
and under agitate them
and what happens then is that you're
going to see things settling out over
time just like you'd see with italian
salad dressing breaking into layers
right and if particles remain settled
out for too long it can be difficult or
impossible to resuspend them this can
lead to obstructed hoses or piping
and for liquid active ingredients before
you add them you want to check the
container of the storage tank to make
sure that mixture is mixed in the tank
right before you even add it or sorry in
the container before you even enter the
tank
and this should help keep things evenly
distributed
so i just want to give you an agitation
example and this is from a professor in
plant pathology microbiology his name is
dr david rosenberger and he was using
nordx75wg it's a fungicide for selecting
buying crops and field and veg crops in
greenhouse ornamental
so you can see that the nordocs label
language
it states agitate the mixture to
maintain a uniform suspension and david
ran into problems trying to apply this
product with poor agitation okay so the
product settled to the bottom of the
tank it remained as a sludge
after the liquid was sprayed out and so
in david's case he said just reviewing
that statement on the label or even a 10
to 15 minute jar test would have
forewarned him of the settling problems
beforehand we're going to talk about jar
tests later on
so the next thing you want to think
about is the properties of your carrier
and those can greatly influence
compatibility we're first going to talk
about ph
so ph just measures the degree to which
a substance is acidic or basic
so lemon juice
for example has a ph of 2. it's pretty
acidic
ammonia has a ph of 12 and it's more
basic and then water is supposed to have
a ph that's close to neutral or 7 but
we're going to talk about how this is
not always true
so most pesticides perform best if your
carrier's ph is you know four to six
point five or so okay so they do better
in slightly acidic conditions uh one
exception would be the
cell phone urea herbicides and they
perform best at slightly basic
ph of seven to eight
when your ph is out of range for your
particular pesticide products can fall
out of solution they can degrade and
decompose and this will happen faster if
the ph is more extreme or the
temperature is higher and they can also
lose their electrical charge and this
can reduce the product penetration into
weeds so reduce efficacy so clearly it's
really important that your ph be optimal
for pesticides to be effective and to
ensure they're compatible how do you
make sure that the ph is addressed
properly when you're tank mixing
okay i don't want you to get overwhelmed
by this chart but i want you to realize
that you know the ph of your water
sources can be really variable and so
this was a chart from a study that was
done in 1986 um and basically what it's
showing there's ph for different water
sources in the fruit growing regions of
new york state
okay so you have these different regions
and you can see the ph ranges and what i
want you to focus on is really just that
the range is so variable in some of
these similar regions and then across
the season you can also see that uh you
see a difference in the ph range you
know from summer to fall spring in these
same areas
okay so ph can shift both seasonally and
within the same place and a lot of times
these shifts especially in surface water
um
can be because of sediments and
microorganisms and minerals that are in
flux
okay but the bottom line is just don't
assume that you know the ph even if you
tested it you know last year okay you
need to be testing your water source
really frequently
and so you want to measure the ph of
your water sources several times
throughout the season you want to test
your water probably a couple weeks
before your spray regime begins and
that'll give you time to kind of
evaluate your water make sure you know
which products will be optimal with your
water source
and also which ph adjusters or adjuvants
you might want to have on hand
and to measure ph you can use an
electronic ph meter or ph dye strips and
both of those can be found
pretty easily online
also labels may direct you to measure ph
at different times during the mixing
process
okay but you always want to measure ph
after mixing
and then you want to add your ph
adjusters if you need to adjust the ph
with care
okay ph adjusters like water
conditioners or adjuvants um
you know they might be prohibited by the
label and sometimes just specific ones
are prohibited so you want to make sure
that what you add is effective and
compatible with your product
acidifiers can be
they can lower the ph of the tank
sometimes they can lower it too much
okay and that can cause your active
ingredients to precipitate out of
solution or even volatilize oh hi
hello
karen i think that you are i'm just
going to mute karen here unless you had
a question
all right
um
so you want to keep in mind that the
label may require adding adding the
conditioner first or at some other time
during the mixing process okay so don't
assume that you always add at the end
and you should be aware of product
degradation over time as well with
different ph okay so an active
ingredient can become ineffective after
10 hours when the ph is five but it can
only last you two minutes at a ph of
nine okay these aren't exact numbers i'm
giving you but it really can be
dramatically different
um so purdue university's extension
publication that i was looking over
shares these following rules of thumb
for most pesticides okay so if your
mixture is you know 3.5 to 6 ph
you're going to want to apply that
mixture within 12 to 24 hours
if your ph is a little closer to neutral
you want to apply it within one to two
hours
and if your ph is more than seven you
want to apply that immediately and
remember this rule of thumb is only for
uh you know most pesticides we talked
about how most pesticides do well
and the ph is a little more acidic so
the sulfonylureal herbicides uh wouldn't
match these timeframes
but this just gives you an idea that you
know things can really degrade over time
and the best rule of thumb of course is
to just mix right before you apply you
don't have to worry about any of this
um
the label will not always mention water
ph okay
so
that doesn't mean it won't cause an
incompatibility problem what's going to
happen often is the manufacturer just
might assume that your water ph will be
in a normal range and they may not be
able to warn you you know about an out
of range ph issue because they're not
assuming that you have an out of range
ph
and you want to avoid mixing pesticides
with radically different ph requirements
because what would happen is that you're
always trying to condition for one
pesticide and that would mean that
you're kind of reducing the efficacy and
performance of the other right they're
if they're radically different needs for
the ph range so for instance li 700 can
help acidify spray water so products
like captain and median don't degrade so
that's useful for captain and edan but
if he were to mix
li-700 with copper fungicides for
instance for instance um that can cause
phytotoxicity at low ph right so you
really have to be careful
um
and you should just avoid mixing
pesticides that have radically different
ph requirements
so next we'll talk about water hardness
another factor that can influence
compatibility is water hardness
so negatively charged pesticide
molecules have a tendency to attach or
attract to positively charged cat ion
cations that are naturally found in
water
so these include things like aluminum
iron calcium sodium and magnesium
the pesticides that bind with these
minerals can actually precipitate out of
solution
or they might be less likely to enter
the target test
so weak acid herbicides like glyphosate
or dodean or 24d and dicamba
are more susceptible to incompatibility
in hard water
and you can see from this map i have in
the u.s
that the natural concentration of these
minerals in hard water so water hardness
red is like the most hard water right it
really varies across the country you can
see the hardest water is sort of in the
middle of the country uh a little bit
more out west from us but you can also
if you look at new york state there's
some red parts of our state
okay and there's a lot of variation with
across our state so you really want to
be careful that you know what the water
hardness is where you are
so let's take a pause here and think
about why would water hardness render
pesticides ineffective
so what i'm showing here is uh two
containers the one on the left contains
distilled water
uh so it has zero water hardness and the
one on the right
contains hard water a lot of minerals
concentration okay and a material that
mimics glyphosate is going to be added
to both these bottles and you'll notice
that the water on the left remains clear
and this indicates that the added
product is in solution okay so that's
what you want
the water on the right is cloudy and
what this is indicating is that the
calcium has actually bound to the
glyphosate mimic okay
and so
if the mixture on the right were to be
applied
there would not be any glyphosate
available to act on your weeds because
it would have already bound to the hard
water
even if you're adding the full rate to
your tank you're just not going to get
any efficacy because it's bound to the
hard water and of course if you think
about this this is like on a continuum
right so if you have a really high
concentration
um you're going to see something like
this where it's completely ineffective
but there might be
different degrees of
efficacy depending on how hard your
water is
so to avoid water hardness issues you'll
want to measure water hardness with
commercially available water testing
kits
and if your water is out of the normal
range water softeners like ammonium
sulfate or ams and ammonium thiosulfate
can counter the effects of hardness but
you want to be careful because adding
ams to things like ec formulations can
sometimes result in phytotoxicity and
hopefully
you know it should be on the label
language so here's an example this is
angenia this product is an herbicide
listed for dt soybean new york
and there's instructions to use a
conditioning agent if your water iron
content's above 500 ppm so you have hard
water you're like all right i'm going to
use this conditioning agent but the
label dictates not to use the more
common ones so ams or uan and instead um
you have to use conditioners that are
pre-approved for ingenious you actually
have to go look those up right and i
think they're in a different section of
the label but this is really important
also in this label there's a statement
that talks about noting that the ph
buffering agent that's required for this
product okay
so there's a you you know this is
another exception of why there's so many
uh exceptions and complications another
example
of why you have to check the label
we're also going to talk about water
turbidity
so water hardness was when negatively
charged pesticides were attracted to cat
ions and weren't available to act in
your pests
with water turbidity what you have is
positively charged pesticides that are
attracted to and bind
um to negatively charged particles in
your water
so what are the negatively charged
particles that are in your water well
they're things like soil sediment
so in general just do not mix pesticides
with water that is visibly muddy or
murky because this will lead to
incompatibility
or could
um
sometimes a label will talk about
turbidity issues you probably can't see
this as well but this is glyphosate plus
and the label states
reduced results may occur if water
containing soil is used such as visibly
muddy water or water from ponds and
ditches that it's not clear
and last when we're thinking about
carrier properties let's talk about
temperature
so water temperature influences the rate
at which products dissolve disperse
emulsify and flow
and more materials will dissolve in
warmer water than in colder water
you can see this diagram here the cold
water is just not moving as fast so it's
not going to be able to bump into your
pesticides as much and interact with
them as much
and that's why they don't dissolve as
much as they do with warm water
when you have cold or water dry and
liquid flowable formulations will take
longer to disperse
ecs crop oil and seed oil formulations
will form gels and kind of distribute
unevenly in the tank
and water-soluble packets may not
dissolve as easily they may take a
really long time to dissolve
so how do you avoid compatibility issues
with cold water
if you're working with colder water
you'll want to agitate the water more
you're going to wait for longer for
those products to dissolve
and you maybe even want to create pretty
slurries in warmer water to ensure the
products are distributing evenly so you
put them in warm water first before you
add them to the cold tank water
and keep in mind that temperature is
usually not addressed on the label
because it's assumed that you're working
with water that's within the right
temperature range
so how cold is too cold
unfortunately there's not enough
research on this for me to really give
you an exact range hopefully more comes
out
but what i can show you is research data
purdue which is summarizing this table
so what they did in the study is they
mix the
you know the following herbicides here
with different temperature water and the
extras show where the herbicide
performance was reduced and maybe it
wasn't reduced completely but you know
it was reduced in some way for at least
some weed species and the checks show
where their products were effective
and so you even though they only tested
four products this information you know
could help you think about things
because what you're seeing is that
you know if the water's at 72
these herbicides were effective and then
it wasn't when the water was as cold as
41. and so as your water gets farther
away from 72 and closer to 41 you're
going to want to think about increasing
agitation waiting longer for products to
dissolve
and creating those pre-slurries and warm
water
one of the most important tools that you
have at your disposal to avoid
incompatibility is to test before you
mix in the tank with a small amount of
product with the jar test
you're probably familiar with these but
you should always conduct a jar chest if
you're mixing products that you have not
mixed before because you don't know if
those will be incompatible you don't
want to experiment with an untested tank
mixing data application you should also
do periodic jar tests with products that
you actually have mixed already this is
because manufacturers can often change
the inert ingredients that are in their
products
and
sometimes another factor such as your
carrier ph or water hardness could
change over time and that might impact
compatibility the jar test could
actually catch that for you right
remember there's no recovery once you've
mixed things in the tank if you're
having incompatibility issues um or
often no recovery right the jar test can
really save you from losing product and
having a mess to clean up
when you do a jar test you're looking
for the following indicators of
incompatibility and we talked about you
know it's really hard to flag chemical
incompatibility you often can't see it
but sometimes the mixture will give off
heat
um or sometimes you're going to see
something looking cloudy kind of like
that glyphosate hard water example that
i showed you
so you might be able to catch chemical
incompatibility certainly you're going
to be able to catch physical
incompatibilities
um
you know you're going to see layers
forming or the mixture isn't uniform if
particles are floating or foaming maybe
you're going to see residue accumulating
on the sides of the container or
material that just takes a really long
time just
to
settle to the bottom
or larger particles are present that
would not fit through your screens
filters or nozzles
when you conduct the jar test you're
going to use the exact same water that
you use in the tank
because you know we know that water ph
hardness uh turbidity can all make a
difference
and then
you know the labels usually tell you uh
how to do a jar test but it usually
involves measuring cups and glass or
plastic containers and don't reuse those
for other purposes right just for
pesticides and you can purchase chemical
compatibility test kits online if you
need to with all the supplies needed
to conduct the test you're going to mix
the appropriate amounts of carrier and
pesticide you're going to make sure you
use enough water and you would start by
adding what you know the carrier that's
needed about one-fifth to one-half carry
needed you're going to mix the
proportionate amount of pesticides in
the recommended order
then you're going to add the rest of the
carrier and you invert the container
after adding a product
once you've mixed your products in the
jar you're going to let it stand for at
least 30 minutes now if you can let it
stand for longer that'll give you more
information if a pesticide were to
degrade overnight for instance if your
jar test can go overnight
and maybe you know that's how long your
mixture is going to be in the tank that
would really let you know if you're
going to have an incompatibility issue
and to drive home why you need enough
water here in the left we have
um
you know pesticide products touchdown
and flexstar mixed with
liquid ams and water on the left we only
have 25 milliliters of water and on the
right we have the recommended 80
milliliters of water you know it's just
based on the proportions right and so if
you don't use the right proportion you
can see that the one on the left is much
less close to being compatible than the
one
on the right
where enough water was added
all right so we're getting close to the
end here but i'm going to kind of throw
a bunch of extra
tips at you here so i want you to think
about you know
compatibility is really holistic we've
been going into each little aspect of it
but actually it's really important to
look at things overall
um and there's many things to to take
into account all at once so i have an
example here and it's captain
and
it's a fungicide label for fruit
ornamentals um
and what you can see is that the label
warns that mixing caftan with alkaline
materials like spray lime and bordeaux
mix can reduce the fungicidal activity
of the product
um and this is because the liquid lime
sulfur has an extremely high ph so it
can degrade captain so that's the first
thing you want to watch out for
then the label mentions that you should
not apply captain close to oil sprays
and the reason why is because the oil
can actually make your plant cuticle
more permeable and this means that
captain could enter the plant and cause
phytotoxicity
next the label states that
there might be problems with captain and
photo toxicity and those problems sorry
the problems with captain of better
toxicity can get worse after an extended
period of cloudy and damp weather so
you're going to have to look out for the
weather and the reason why this is is
because you know new leaves are going to
be growing when it's cloudy and damp
and then those new leaves will have less
cuticular waxes it'll be easier for
captain to accidentally penetrate and
damage the plant
also the label will discourage the use
of spreaders that cause excessive
wetting and this is because much like
with the oils adding adjuvants that
increase penetration into the plant can
cause damage to your plant vital
toxicity
and then finally the label talks about
organophosphates and sulfur
um for example flint which contains
phosphate in its formulation when it's
sprayed around the same time as captain
it can result in phytotoxicity so this
just shows how many things you have to
keep in mind when you're trying to avoid
incompatibility
and like with many things that are this
complicated there's always additional
rules of thumb so i talked to some
cornell extension cooperative extension
educators and scientists and i just want
to share the following tips with you
and um steve how are we doing on time
we've got uh we've got another 10
minutes or so
okay great yeah so i might go a little
bit over the 50 minutes but we'll still
have time for questions okay so um here
are some of the additional rules of
thumb and i wanted to share this with
you because you know i was talking to
people that work with fruit and veg
growers so i think this is really
helpful to keep in mind
so the first thing i want to talk about
is you want to keep in mind that
phytotoxicity can be specific to
specific crops and cultivars okay
so
read the labels really carefully and
don't assume that things will be true
across all cultivars for example apogee
this is a product that can cause
fruit cracking on empire and stamen
apples but it's safe on other cultivars
okay and even if you aren't tank mixing
you want to be careful
with tank
residues
so for example as oxy strobin
will cause leaf and fruit burn on some
apple cultivars even if it's just in the
slightest amount like in parts per
billion okay so this could be a
situation where you don't clean out your
tank as well as
you know you hope to after spraying
exoxy and pumpkins or something right
then you later spray an apple and
there's only a tiny bit of that esoxy
strogan but it can damage
um
the apples
you also want to make sure your
ingredients are fresh
so for example if you're an apple grower
you might know that lime absorbs carbon
dioxide and the reason why apple growers
might know this is because paper bags of
lime were actually traditionally placed
in controlled atmosphere apple storage
and the reason why is because they
absorb carbon dioxide and this reduced
injury to stored apples
but now think about other uses you might
have for lime if you make bordeaux mix
with spray lime and copper sulfate
imagine what might happen if you're
using some of the older spray line that
you were storing in paper bags if you
didn't seal that spray lime up it
probably absorbs some carbon dioxide and
so just like with the glyphosate in the
hard water example that i showed um
you know it will have bound to
the carbon dioxide and that lime will no
longer combine with the copper sulfate
because it's just not going to be
available and so the copper is going to
be less effective
so keep in mind how fresh your
ingredients are
and then i also want to talk about name
brand versus generic i'm going to be
really careful here and say this is just
anecdotal evidence okay there's not you
know proven studies on this or anything
but from people who have worked closely
with apple and vegetable growers what
i'm hearing is that there's reports of
mixing issues and also crop damage with
some of your cheaper or off brand
formulations and so the reason why is
because cheaper formulations can have
varying amounts of surfactant
or varying quality of the inert
ingredients
okay so even though the active
ingredient is the same between the two
different
products the one that's off-brand
you know you might have to add more
surfactant
or uh
there's just less quality so for example
um
with glyphosate for instance some of
those off-brand products that have legs
as the active ingredient might require
more surfactants and that can increase
the chances of like say uptake of an
injury to
tree bark
and then also you know
if you have different quality of your
inert ingredients
we're seeing some generic formulations
that sometimes don't mix as well with
the name brands for
instance bravo weather stick
and that's probably because those inner
ingredients just not being as quality
and then finally be careful
uh which products you mix with
biological products okay
because products like fungicides
sanitizers or bacteria size can kill
those biologically active ingredients
and if they're dead they're definitely
not going to be effective against your
past
so we talked a lot about how to prevent
incompatibility before you even
you know have the problem
that's your first line of defense but
what if you do run into unexpected
incompatibility in your tank what do you
do
when you first notice it you're going to
contact your dealer or product
manufacturer to talk about options
worst case scenario they can tell you
how to dispose of the solution in a way
that you know causes the least risk to
you and poses the least risk to the
environment and your equipment
they also might direct you to add a
conditioner or an adjuvant that could
improve the situation
these could be things like more water a
compatibility agent a detergent soap
non-ionic surfactant or a ph adjuster
and even if that added product resolves
the incompatibility it doesn't mean that
your product will be effective anymore
right so you'll want to check with the
dlr manufacturer to know if your product
will still work or if if you just
resolve it in compatibility enough to
not damage your equipment
and then you also want to check is the
problem isolated to your spray tank
if not
you may need to dismantle your sprayer
to remove any residues
so i think that that's all that i have
and i am ready to take questions
uh mary i will just say to you thank you
so much for making
a very complicated subject i think uh
rather easy to follow
and uh
i hope people feel that way i hope i
didn't bore you all to tears
no it's such an important subject too so
i thought it was really fascinating too
in terms of like the order to put things
in
um and how to do that so again thank you
for that
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu